اذا لا تهاون مع من يعبث باسرار الدوله
بايضا وترامب ان يعلمان حساسيه هذه النقطه
وكلاهما يراهن على سقوط الاخر اعلاميا
كبرت كره الثلجي كثيرا فالحرب انتقلت من
المنصات الرقميه الى اروقه الكونجرس معركه
اخرى تضاف الى معارك انتهت احداها اخيرا
بعد 14 جوله بفوز جمهوريه برئاسه مجلس
النواب مدارس ولجنه المراقبه جيمس كومير
باطلاق طلبات رسميه للحصول على معلومات
حول الوثائق وتفاصيل اكتشافها والسجل
الاتصالات بين وزاره العدل وفريق بايدن
وطلب كومر البيت الابيض والخدمه السريه
بسجلات الزائرين لمنزل بايدن في ديلاور
كما نبه رئيس الاركان من ان سوء تعامل
بايدن مع المواد السريه يثير مساله تعريض
الامن القومي للخطر كذلك فعل النائب
الجمهوري جيم جوردن اعلن عن تحقيق في مع
التركيز بشكل اولي على قرار المدعي العام
تعيين مستشارا خاص وبالمناسبه من لكن من
ترامبوا بايدن يعلم الديمقراطيون ان
موقفهم ربما اضعف في هذه المرحله ويرفضون
التعليق الى حين صدور نتيجه المستشار
الخاص لكن هناك من
اعترف هناك ايضا من الديمقراطيين من يقف
في المنتصف لنستمع
اذا كما قلنا هناك من يقف في المنتصف ايضا
كزعيم الاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ تشاك تشومر
هذه الاطراف تدعم تشريع الحزبين بهدف
الحفاظ على السجلات الرئاسيه والفدراليه
بشكل عام موقفه قد لا يكون الانسب لحزبه
لكنه الاذكى في معركه لم تتضح نتيجتها بعد
وباحسن الاحوال ويكرر على ما اكد عليه
صديقه ومنافسه القديم
كشف عن دواء الثلاث لكن ترتيب حدوثها
الزمني المثالي لاستمراري مسلسل قضائيه
يتزامن مع انطلاق الحملات الانتخابيه
لسباق 2024 الرئاسي ان كانت مساله سوء
التعامل مع الوثائق السريه امر شائع
فالسؤال هنا لماذا تتكرر هناك مؤسسه يخصص
لها يخصص لها 500 مليون دولار سنويا
للقيام بمهمه محدده وهي الحفاظ على
المستندات الحكوميه الخلل في منظومه
التصنيف والعدد يتجاوز الخمسين مليون
وثيقه سنويا يجعل تتبع جميعها امرا صعبا
ان لم يكن مستحيلا وبالنسبه لاليه التصنيف
غالبا ما يلجا الرؤساء للخيار الاكثر حيث
تصنف جميع انواع المعلومات على انها سريه
خوفا من تسريبها للاعداء او الخصوم لكن
الافراط في التصنيف السري يعيق العمل
الصحفي ويتسبب بالتلاعب في الراي العام
والاهم ربما يسهل التهرب من المحاسبه
فالسريه لها مستويات وفقا للحساسيه
والخطوره بسبب تلك الوثائق شديده السريه
يقضي نزلاء هذا البيت والطاقم المتصل به
اصعب لحظات في حياتهم المهنيه وتحديدا هنا
في الجناح الغربي في مساحه تقدر بخمسه
الاف وخمسمائه قدم اي بحجم مستودع صغير
الحجم تقريبا هناك انشات انشات غرفه
العمليات بامر من الرئيس جون كندي عام 61
ويديرها منذ ذلك الوقت ضباط الاستخبارات
على مدار 24 ساعه في اليوم وهي نتائج قرار
اتخذ بعد فشل غزوه خليج الخنازير بسبب نقص
المعلومات في الوقت الحقيقي لحدوثها اليوم
تشكل هذه الغرفه النقطه المحوريه لتلقي
وتوزيع جميع التقارير الحكوميه منها
السريه للغايه التي توضع على الطاوله وت
وتطبخ على اثرها قرارات تؤثر على العالم
وتصنف الملفات السريه بحسب حساسيتها فمنها
لا يمكن قراءته الا من قبل فردا مسمى او
من مواقع محدده ومنها ما لا يمكن مشاركته
مع اي حكومه او فردا اجنبي باستثناء
مجموعه العيون الخمس اي تحالف الولايات
المتحده بريطانيا كندا استراليا
ونيوزيلندا والنيتو وتبقى هذه الغرفه على
اتصال بالرئيس الامريكي اينما وجد عبر
منشاه متنقله خاصه بالمعلومات الحساسه
المجزئه وهذه المنشاه مجهزه ومحصنه من اي
اختراق الكترونيا محتمل